as restoration work goes on to the
outside of Britain's houses of
parliament a comprehensive renewal has
taken place inside Boris Johnson's
landslide election victory means
legislation for the UK's long-awaited
withdrawal from the European Union is
well on its way to being approved
that leaves ratification by the EU
Parliament to allow brexit to happen at
the end of January with a transition
period to follow meaning little change
on the ground until at least the end of
next year for governments in and after
years of tough often acrimonious
negotiations it is possible that 2020
will see Britain's exit from the
European Union become law but don't
expect that to be the end of the brexit
pain few here in Brussels do renewal -
inside EU institutions new commission
president ursula von der Leyen
says she's keen to preserve good
relations with the United Kingdom in
negotiations to come over the future
relationship but EU interests will
always come first and I think the danger
in terms of UK EU relations is that
again things get pretty tense between
the two sides with the pressure from the
UK side to get things done very quickly
and the EU side saying there's that's
just not feasible unless you're willing
to you know do things are we
Prime Minister Johnson insists a trade
deal can and must be struck by the end
of 2020 with no extension here in
Brussels you know people who are
veterans of this kind of process and
with other countries you know say it
takes much longer a year of more
negotiating redlines rhetoric and
brinksmanship lies ahead and back in
London the prospect that by next
December Britain once again risks
reaching no deal with the EU the one
thing that we do know about Prime
Minister Johnson is that he's put a lot
of quite obvious red lines in his
manifesto no single market and no
customs union no role for the European
Court of Justice there's much a lot to
his supporters but the other thing we
know from Boris Johnson tegoshi ation so
far is
he can be flexible when he sees a deal
in sight brexit promises have been
broken ultimatums reversed the
undeliverable delivered in 2020 then
expect the unexpected
jonah hull al-jazeera London